today as Tory MP Mike Freer is forced to
give up politics after death threats
from islamists and their supporters I
want to ask whether we're simply giving
in now to extremist Constantine joins me
now look thank you very very much look
today I am legitimately incredibly angry
we've got an MP who is frankly having to
give up because of largely islamist
extremism a prime minister who doesn't
feel the need to say anything publicly
about that a leader of the opposition
who doesn't feel the need to say
publicly anything about I mean what the
heck is going on
here well Patrick we shouldn't be
surprised you remember of course very
well the tragic murder s David Ames
after which cowardly MP after MP both
Tor and Labour went into the chamber
after their colleague which has been
murdered by an Islamic extremist uh and
pretended that he had in fact been
murdered by a tweet uh when they talked
endlessly about online hate digital harm
the Online safety Bill uh to do uh the
one thing that they always do which is
avoid naming the problem which is we
have a major issue with islamist
extremists in this country uh who are
using violence to intimidate other
people into silence and into uh doing
whatever it is they want and as long as
we continue to cower and bow down to
this it will continue because one of the
most depressing things about uh watching
the reactions today is as you've alluded
to not only have the prime minister or
the leader of the opposition said
anything but actually nobody has
anything to say even the people who are
deeply concerned as you and I are
they're not saying we must have a task
force within the police or we must do X
or we must do y they're all expressing
their concern I have had enough of
people's concern I would like the
government to actually do something and
the police to actually do something to
the point where maybe an elected Member
of Parliament can go about their
business without being threatened into
submission could we maybe have that is
that unreasonable to ask in a Democratic
free country like ours well no it's not
but again today lindsy Hoy who I think
he's probably all right decides to come
out and say look you MPS need to be
nicer to each other I'm sorry but it's
not MPS that have made Mike fre quit is
it it's not MPS that stabbed David Amos
to death it's not MPS who are rampaging
through London every single Saturday
with anti-semitic signs and occasionally
beating up Jewish people that they
happen to pass in the street you know we
have a massive problem here is radical
islamist
ideology it's been allowed into Britain
hasn't it Conan and people like you have
been have been calling this out why have
we developed this massive self-loathing
in Britain do you think well one of the
things first of all that shows the level
of fear and cowardice and self-loathing
that we have is the fact that a couple
of weeks ago you'll remember Patrick I'm
sure you covered on the show The Banning
of the islamist group hisb Tera uh hisb
teria was banned in the UK finally a
couple of weeks ago do you know uh other
countries where hisb has been banned for
a long time Pakistan Bangladesh every
Arab country but three every Muslim
country in Central Asia Indonesia the
most populous country in the world and
what it shows you is we basically are
more tolerant of islamist extremist than
Muslim countries are and the Muslim
rulers are and the Muslim governments
are and so I just and to say nothing of
the fact of course a a subject that has
been covered both on on GB news and on
trigonometry uh The Grooming GS again
why were they not given the attention
and the police action that they should
have been given because people were
afraid and initially sensitivities about
quote race and diversity become fears uh
when we allow people to use violence to
silence people into an action so until
we have a leader or a government or a
police Constable or chief Constable or
whoever it is that actually gets a grip
of this issue and says we are not going
to tolerate violent extremists in our
country silencing MPS this will continue
and it will only get worse yeah indeed
but they're also going to have to be up
for the fight Conant and this is frankly
a problem I can see coming a mile off
right which is I don't think they are
clearly not I mean they're all at the
moment willing to just roll over and
have their bellies tickled by a load of
mad islamists right and they're going to
have to be prepared for massive protests
they're going to have to be prepared for
death threats they're going to have to
be prepared for people lining up outside
primary schools and trying to shut them
down they're going to have to be
prepared for all of this stuff but the
fact that they have to be prepared for
it surely shows that we have a massive
problem and I don't know about you but I
think there's a lot to lose here in
Briton we have got a lot to lose and
just before I get your answer on this I
know that you think that there's a lot
to lose in Britain because this is what
happened when you were on question time
just saying I hope you don't find this
iny you some quite basic stuff about how
Great Britain is right constan why did
you get that reaction How concerned
should we be
well one of the things that you would
not have seen on your TV screen Patrick
but you would have seen if You' been
there in the audience or on the panel is
actually she was not the only one
shouting you may have heard other male
voices shouting as well so there were
several people uh who were so offended
by the idea that Britain is actually a
really nice country that they felt the
need to shout me down H and I think uh
in her case as we later discovered it
speaks to an issue that we've covered uh
obviously quite extensively now which is
we're educating young people to hate
their own country uh there's no doubt
about that and one of the things that
happened with this young woman
afterwards one of her tweet uh one of
her teachers tweeted at me saying how
proud she is of her student for shouting
down somebody on the panel uh so and
when I pointed the S she of course
blocked me because these people can dish
it out but they can't take it however my
point is this if we continue to be a
society that teaches its young people to
hate their own country their own values
their own civil ization then we will
have this and at the same time of course
there is the Unholy Alliance of the the
kind of woke Progressive left and
islamists uh who who who work handin
hand uh and um you know as long as we
continue to have that we will continue
to have the problem so the number one
thing that I always try to tell British
people is uh the country is not perfect
of course the culture is not perfect the
history is not perfect but this is a
great place by comparison to everywhere
else that has ever existed in the
history of humanity and we have to
embrace our values and the most
important thing that you can do uh is
teach your children the values of your
Society the importance of valuing what
you have of being grateful for the
opportunity to enjoy the privilege that
no one ever talks about but is the one
privilege that we all have which is
first world privilege and if people were
actually to understand just how
fortunate and lucky they are to be
living in societies that are is free and
as prosperous still as ours are maybe at
that point we wouldn't listen to the
lunatics who sh to and want to talk down
our country as much as these people
do